the Florida Republicans who gathered for
a victory party were being told to
prepare for defeat
the exit poll predicted a Clinton win
which would pretty much guarantee her
the presidency but then they started
counting the real votes and things were
looking up and up
he's been my candidate from day one
because he's not a politician kind of
like Britain we're sick of them
across town at the equivalent gathering
of Democrats the mood was heading in the
opposite direction I'm sickened I'm
without words I thought for sure that
Hillary would win this election that
Hillary would win Florida if he can get
you know worried about a tweet or he's
insecure about his image and he has his
finger on the nuclear button what does
that mean for the world
victory was slipping away soon the rest
of the key swing states were following
suit then when Trump's victory in
Florida was confirmed this is a result
which may have confounded the pollsters
and pundits they shot the rest of the
world the people who voted for and
campaign for Donald Trump they aren't
surprised he's now heading for the White
House people believed in him he's going
to do exactly he's gonna be everything
then he says he's going to be everybody
believes in him I'm so happy and I'm so
proud I'm so I'm so proud to call him
the President of the United States
because that's what's about to happen
across the country it was a similar
story North Carolina and Georgia back
Trump I'm not a deportable I'm just the
blue firewall of what should have been
reliably Democrat States was being
chipped away Wisconsin Michigan Ohio all
fell headquarters looks pretty somber go
Trump hoorah
it was a stunning reversal of the Obama
years a result which hardly anyone
predicted the people had spoken and the
answer they gave suggested Washington
had been ignoring them for too long the
in Woods Sky News Tampa Florida